hello everyone cared mornin with film
courage the radio show or outside the
studio with kyle patrick alvarez after
our interview and we had a wonderful
chat we had some skype callers as well
and one question we didn't get to during
the show is you know hindsight being
twenty-twenty what have you learned with
easier with practice that you're now
applying to see OG and girls i think the
biggest thing I learned was that at the
end of the day it's better to stick with
you know you think when you you try to
always go back to that place that what
was it that motivated you to start
making the film in the first place and
always take that with you every step
along the way so that's what I'm trying
to do now with with you know doing a
genre picture and doing this new thing
was like going to like what was that
first feeling I had that I got so
excited I go I write this is no
scripting and give you this I can trying
to remember that because there's so many
things are so many elements there's
money there's so many people there's
actors there's agents there's industry
there's distribution all the other stuff
we could talk about but in the end of
the day all you're really trying to do
is capture that first spark of
excitement you got and so staying true
to that I think is what I learned that
I'm going to at least hopefully aspire
to to continue on through my projects
and at the end of the day be like oh I'm
just as hopefully just as excited about
it as the first day I had the idea so if
you know you have that spark what about
the times when there's that inertia
where it's like you know what this is
dragged on for a while and I just don't
want to sit at the computer and look at
this today I I think everybody's been
there how do you fight through that
though how do you reek indle that when
maybe it's died a little bit yeah I
think I you know fatigue because you
have to spend years you know with one
thing
usually and you know what for me it's
sometimes it's usually like music or
like specific scenes you know it's like
I owe either some that I can always go
back to and every project I'm like
that's the scene i want to make the
movie for you know and everything is
built around that it's that great quote
I'm gonna forget who said it but like I
think it's I think it's not Howard Hawks
someone said it was like a good move a
movie needs three good scenes and no bad
ones you know like I always the end like
in this that sounds a little cynical but
i think it's like there's always I think
you think like that's the beat that's
the moment you know that I want to make
that movie for and that's that initial
spark and instead of being like and
usually I just remember and it's usually
like a song i was thinking over there
was listening to know i was writing that
I associate with the movie whether it
ends up being on the soundtrack or not
but something like that that when i'm
getting a little like I or whatever I go
back to that initial thing and I'm like
oh that's right that's what it felt with
some kind of sense memory now that
sounds like i'm talking like an actor
but you know like a sense memory thing
that reminds you what you return what
you're hoping to capture